all we've got the rock band games the
Gertz our hero games they're all coming
back in a big way Guitar Hero live
versus rock band 4 we are here to check
in on which one is leading the pack in
sort of the mid summer stretch on route
to fall release Mike McCarty and Justin
hey Walt thank you guys for joining me
thanks for having us
all right guys a couple of couple of
plastic Rock superstars over here from
what I've seen you might say that I I
mean I I've toured the world the living
rooms fans by the basement billions all
around I'm a rug gun you might say we
got the chance to play some guitar here
live last week they brought it by we got
to strum away it was my first time with
the new guitar very cool sort of you
know the three three and three buttons
as opposed to five right in a row and I
think that sort of as this as the
release of these games is starts to loom
closer and closer it's the old rivalry
is back our hero
rock band that's what people are ones
like that's the question that you're
wonder like which is the one that I'm
gonna get cuz it's an expensive prospect
to like not only get the game to get
more of these plastic instruments to
take up the room in your your living
room mm-hmm like is it gonna be worth it
to reinvest in rock band is it worth it
to get this new guitar and it's too
early to say definitively like this game
is better than that game we spent so
little time with both of them but we
definitely have an idea of where we're
at so far based on what we played yeah
so let's talk about what we do know we
know Guitar Hero has a new guitar mic do
you think that is the case for guitar
hero or against it it's definitely a
case for I like you recently just got my
first hands-on time with it and I really
liked it it was kind of weird because I
was really looking for a new reason to
get back into Guitar Hero specifically
because that was definitely that kind of
fell into second place for me back when
I was still playing rhythm games I loved
rock band but I grew up on Guitar Hero
so being able to have like it's kind of
like two strings now almost cuz you can
do frets you do frets on the older ones
too but it was still wasn't I guess it's
more realistic in a way but the classic
two string guitar yeah yeah so it was it
was it took a little while to get used
to I mean you seem to you guys are both
seem to grab it right away yeah it's a
novel experience I mean it's cuz it's
not
a single button but there's two rows of
buttons and so you have to work with
sort of different elevations of your
fingers and yeah you get that like
familiar cramping when you're like
trying something really hard with your
hand for the first time it doesn't work
out so well but then you get the hang of
it and so Justin do you feel like it's a
the novelty of that play experience or
Mike do you feel like that's a powerful
draw yeah that's one of the things that
I've always loved about those games like
I've played guitar hero since before
there was Guitar Hero when it was that
you know the different beatmania games
from Konami and like this game came out
I didn't think would live up to it
Guitar Hero was amazing and just every
iteration of that game that challenge to
make yourself even better on guitar and
like this takes it like it makes your
brain think in a different way and like
that's a lot of fun like I want to take
on this challenge and the way that
they've kind of set it up in the game
makes it feel like it's gonna let you
play against other people in a way
that's gonna challenge you to keep going
that you're gonna go to see peoples
leaderboards and scores on the left-hand
side of the screen and know like I can
do that a little bit better I can aim to
get a better score on that and not only
getting a better score but with a
different set of challenge and finger
set like I want that challenge and I
like I want something new and different
that competitiveness has always sort of
been where Guitar Hero excels is you
know the really tough fingering they're
really like difficult songs and people
striving to master them to me has sort
of been my Guitar Hero experience rock
band on the other hand has generally
been more of a social experience you get
more people playing at the same time and
the question here I guess one of them is
certainly one of hardware because if you
buy Guitar Hero live you're gonna need
to buy the game and the hardware it's
gonna cost you a significant amount but
Harmonix currently working to make sure
rock bands peripherals from the past are
usable in rock band for how do we think
that's going to affect rock band 4
negatively or positively well so I think
it's gonna be about $100 I think it's
what they're aiming for for the new
guitar hero with the guitar and probably
more expensive for if you need to get
some of these new instruments they're
letting you use your old instruments but
I know talking with the Harmonix skies
and mad cats that they are gonna have a
new set of instruments with a new set of
abilities like they're very similar to
what we played before but they are
better and like if I play the game I'm
probably gonna want to upgrade my
intruments as well like that's another
at least $100 you're not gonna haul the
old guitars out of storage like that's
part of the appeal for me is I already
have this stuff it's gonna be more
accessible to not the rock band guitars
those are those are my least favorite
guitars like Guitar Hero has always had
better hardware like it in rock band you
have the the the strum that doesn't
quite click like I never like that the
buttons are always mushy they don't seem
to last as long
Guitar Hero's bet I've always used my
Guitar Hero guitar but playing a little
bit with the new rock band instruments
like they're they're better it's a
higher quality but is that really an
enough like the thing the thing it is
that it's it is like you said a social
experience and that's the thing that's
more fun and that's I think what's
missing from Guitar Hero like I love
being able to do that but whether I have
to buy new instruments or not I want to
have all of those different experiences
and let my friends be able to play drums
or sing and only playing guitar I don't
know if that's enough yeah I mean
especially after you know basically
being spoiled by rock bands they have
three-part vocal harmonies guitars
keyboard drums I mean you know keyboards
not coming back for rock band 4 but
drums guitars harmonies I imagine they
all are well so there's not gonna be a
keyboard in the next rock band that's
the only thing that they're cutting out
integrally right did I that's what I was
trying to say but good clarification I
think I'm not sure if I actually said
that but rock band yeah there's that
social dynamic so Mike you said you were
sort of you know you start got your
start with Guitar Hero but then you
swung towards rock band was it that
social impetus that put you there yeah
definitely I think it was the feeling of
actually kind of being part of a band I
mean I used to when I was very young say
I was in a band but don't ever listen to
us if you somehow find us because we
weren't good but I will rock your band
yeah so just the that feeling of you
know what your friends playing drums
your playing guitar you feel like you're
contributing to a song was awesome and I
think it was very much like a great you
know innovation on the party rhythm
based game and I think that's definitely
an impetus for me to get back into rock
band because guitar hero has again been
that competitive pole for me although
you know with Guitar Hero TV and whatnot
the music video stuff it seems like it
could be make it a little more
accessible and make it like social
something you just jump
to parties and whatnot well that's the
wild card in this it's how they're gonna
do music so rock band I have a
ridiculous library of songs that I
downloaded and I never really got into
that guitar hero but at the same time in
rock and Guitar Hero that you're gonna
have access to music from the very
beginning that's kind of like a music
channel and like that's kind of
appealing like is someone who switched
over to things like Spotify and like
that's how I discover music is just like
well I'm just gonna turn on this radio
basically and listen to stuff being able
to watch music videos and so like here's
music that's being offered you and it's
constantly knew which guitar here is
gonna offer and hopefully well I mean
out of the box it's gonna be free for a
guitar gear or TV there's gonna be some
pricing for individual songs after that
but that amount of lots of content for
free is it's kind of appealing and I
sorry I feel like yeah Guitar Hero TV
specifically more so than live is
something perfect if they're on in a
party because it is like I think it's a
little more accessible it's more
recognizable to people than just the 3d
character animations from the past rock
band and Guitar Hero yeah the fact that
you can just have these music videos
playing and again like Justin said it is
random it's look visually interesting
too I mean and even if you know in
Guitar Hero 5 you were you could play a
party mode that allowed you to just drop
out of guitar and then it would be like
this it would play just a you know
there's no note highway you're just
playing a music video so it can the
social and like it sort of allows for
the ebb and flow of a social situation
as opposed to I think the pitfall that
they were trying to you know one of the
things they're trying to avoid is that
like okay like what song do you want to
play next that scroll Scroll scroll well
I play this one no I don't wanna play -
oh we just played that one yeah but I
really want to you know that's a
selection process like for people who
you know played a fair amount of rock
band and guitar here in the past like
that's a big party experience Guitar
Hero TV taking a shot at trying to
undermine that I mean it goes either way
like it's for my group it was always the
singers choice and like we would just
rotate through all the instruments so
the singer gets up to them like they get
to choose the song get to pick something
you want to sing and taking that away
like I mean there's no vocals so like
it's just a guitar game anyway mm-hmm
but at the same time like I love being
able to sing along with something and
like that's part of that rocking out
experience for me it's it's not just
playing a fake guitar it's that whole
cohesive thing yeah there is that purr
it's aspect yeah you to be clear you can
still be that weird person in the corner
singing but anyway that's gonna happen
no one's gonna be scoring you on that if
you unless you get the three other
people the panel of judges with you know
their numbers and they sort of get your
little Guitar Hero Idol going on right
that's you know DLC plan you could maybe
push this alright so Guitar Hero live
slated for October 10th rock band 4 for
October 6th October is gonna be when you
know this all shakes out and we start to
see which one's gained momentum but as
of now you know we're we're almost in
early August who do you think is sort of
in the lead guitar hero rock band
personally which one you gravitating
towards I'm gonna have to go rock band 4
but only by a little mm-hmm
the hardware is compelling in Guitar
Hero but rock band has all the things
that I already know what love and being
able to sing is a really big part I like
being able to customize my band like I
like having my little character and I
have a stupid hat and the custom guitar
that unlocked its I like it it's cool I
got all these stickers on my plastic axe
um I had my own band when you know we're
playing rock band they were less
sexually androgynous hydrangeas that's a
mouthful yeah it's also gonna be my real
band's name once I look III know this
carries over right like Guitar Hero will
carry directly over to playing wheel
guitar yeah from two strings to six
strings it's just a totally small leap
no big deal all right Mike Justin thank
you guys for coming on talking about
Guitar Hero and Rock Band folks chime in
in the comments and let us know what you
think which one are you leaning towards
which one do you think has a better
campaign so far and I guess we'll all
see how it shakes out coming this
October